hello everybody and welcome to another
Python tutorial we're gonna be building
on the last tutorial which covered the
for else pairing and now what we're
gonna be talking about is the while else
so some sort of idea behind it
so we're only we'll show it with a while
loop instead right so if you miss the
for else loop I'll put a link to it in
the description
again the Wow house pairing here is
gonna work the same as for else and that
the WoW and the else are part of like
the same block let's say or loop
therefore if the loop is allowed to
continue until its end the else
statement and everything under it is
going to be called and you know done
because of this it's you know very
important that you when you reach the
period where you have quote unquote
succeeded right and what you want right
basically think of it as if you read
something where you would have used an
if statement and it rang true then you
need to throw in the break which is
gonna break the rest of the loop
including the else statement so let's
show it a quick example so we're gonna
say x equals 0 and then we're gonna have
a while while x is less than 10 if X is
greater than 5 print X became greater
and 5 else X plus equals 1 now this else
statement is not the one that you need
to pay attention to right this is
pertaining to the if so that's regular
if-else then we have another else
statement here and this is the new one
print did not find any example now as I
said before this might be the way that
you initially want to write this but if
you'll watch let's go ahead and run this
and see if we even get away with it but
we should yeah so we get a lot of X
became greater than fives but we never
actually got you note or else and yeah
we also gave ourselves a nice infinite
loop there because we never actually
cx+ Eagles one part anyway we need the
break so you have to throw in the break
there and now when we throw in the break
we'll run this and we see that X became
greater than five right so it ran this
well ran the Wow and X did become
greater than five it broke and never
actually got to the else statement
now what we could do is X plus equals
let's say 11 right so in this case it
will it will run initially at 11 break
the while loop so it'll never have
actual or get out of the wild live I
suppose so it'll never trigger this
break and it should say did not find any
example by the end of this so now let's
say that let's run that and sure enough
did not find any example because there
was you know never actually reached
within the first run it became greater
than ten so and it was never greater
than five while it was less than ten so
that's kind of an example of the Wow
else now the other thing to keep in mind
too is when you break you know some
people might assert that this else
statement is like a lonely L statement
like it's not actually pertaining to the
Wow but just to show we'll say print and
you know continues the rest of the code
so we run it and even though we hit the
break did not find any example we still
continue on with the rest of the code
just to show that these these are
actually paired together and this is
something built into Python so anyways
that's going to conclude the Wow else
statement now in the next video what
we're gonna be talking about is you can
actually do it's really try except else
so but mostly what you're actually
looking at is except else so anyways
that's what we're gonna be talking about
the next video as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and until next time